[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit lee
frisieren guten abend ihnen allen katja
stresow es war mir später mit der
samstags portion fußball sie sieht so
aus schon genannt und das haben wir
unter anderem für sie vorbereitet
russische angriffe auf den süden der
ukraine
gleichzeitig versuchen tausende das
belagerte mario pohl zu verlassen
mehr eigenverantwortung heute enden fast
alle staatlichen vorgaben zum corona
schutz
und präsidentschaftswahlkampf in
frankreich emanuele makro führt die
umfragen an und mobilisiert seine
anhänger
die usa stocken ihre milliardenschwere
militärhilfe für die ukraine noch einmal
auf laut verteidigungsministerium sollen
unter anderem raketensysteme drohnen und
maschinengewehren wert von 300 millionen
dollar geliefert werden in der ukraine
selbst versucht man so viele zivilisten
wie möglich zu evakuieren eine
lebensgefährliche aufgabe zwischen
hoffen und bangen wie pablo salalah hier
und sarah alaska am beispiel der
eingekesselten stadt mario pohl zeiten
endlich in sicherheit zumindest sie
haben es geschafft aus mariupol
herauszukommen in organisierten bussen
oder mit dem privaten pkw doch der
vereinbarte flucht korridor wurde erneut
beschossen
hierbei der erste anschlag und hier dann
der zweite und vor uns ging eine granate
nieder
heute soll sich ein weiterer konvoi des
roten kreuzes auf dem weg nach mario
pohl gemacht haben in der stadt soll
noch mindestens 100.000 menschen
ausharren ohne strom und fließendes
wasser vor dem krieg lebten
450.000 menschen hier
kämpfe werden aktuell vor allem aus dem
süden des landes gemeldet wie hier in
einer roda in unmittelbarer nähe eines
atomkraftwerks mit sechs reaktorblöcken
das leistungsstärkste europas
aus der region um den ehemaligen meiler
von tschernobyl haben sich die russen
zurückgezogen nach ukrainischen angaben
hätten sich die soldaten dort radioaktiv
kontaminiert eine abordnung der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
machte sich daraufhin vor ort ein bild
wir haben davon gehört dass einige
mitarbeiter kontaminiert wurden aber wir
haben dafür keine bestätigung und wir
haben eine ganze menge expertise hier im
haus was das angeht
in der region um die hauptstadt hier
sollen die russischen truppen weiter auf
dem rückzug sein der flughafen rostock
seit beginn des krieges stark umkämpft
soll wieder unter ukrainischer kontrolle
stehen präsident selensky geht davon aus
dass sich die angriffe jetzt weiter auf
den osten konzentrieren
im osten bleibt die situation extrem
kompliziert russische truppen rücken in
den don was vor und richtung charkiw sie
bereiten neue angriffe vor wir bereiten
eine effektivere verteidigung vor
zerstörte wohnhäuser verlassene straßen
wie hier in sumy im nordosten sieht es
in vielen städten der ukraine aus
jörg brase ist für uns in lemberg jörg
gerade im beitrag gehört die ukraine
fürchtet den vormarsch russischer
truppen richtung osten was hören sie
ja das scheint tatsächlich so zu sein
wir sind natürlich angewiesen auf
meldungen die wir von internationalen
sicherheitsbehörden und vom ukrainische
militär bekommen der ukrainische
generalstab hat gesagt in den
vergangenen 24 stunden hätte es
besonders heftige angriffe in den
provinzen raki flug ans und dann jetzt
gegeben wo eben auch die stadt mariupol
liegt aber sollen auch eine
eisenbahnlinie eine gas pipeline
getroffen worden seien russische truppen
so sagt der generalstab zöge sich im
osten des landes also in den provinzen
entlang der russischen grenze zusammen
würden versuchen ukrainische einheiten
einzukesseln und gleichzeitig wir haben
es gehört werden russische einheiten aus
der umgebung der hauptstadt kiew
abgezogen das heißt im moment sieht es
so aus dass sich tatsächlich das
bewahrheitet was russland was moskau vor
wenigen tagen angekündigt hatte nämlich
dass man sich jetzt voll auf die
sogenannte befreiung des donners
konzentrieren will danke für diese
information live aus lemberg jörg brase
war das
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
sind inzwischen schon
129 millionen euro spenden für die
menschen in der und aus der ukraine
zusammen gekommen die meisten die das
land verlassen haben die sind nach polen
geflohen hier unterstützt die
evangelische diakonie allein 50 projekte
mit diesen spenden manchmal sind es nur
kleine maßnahmen die für die menschen
aber viel bewirken aus krakau berichtet
isabel de la vega victoria matlok ist
diakon in der evangelischen gemeinde in
krakau eigentlich ist die seelsorgerin
doch die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
verändern so vieles
heute wird gebastelt morgen schauen wir
ukrainische märchen an die ich zwar
nicht verstehe aber die ablenkung ist
wichtig für die kinder
als die ersten flüchtlinge in krakau
eintreffen zögert die gemeinde nicht
lange zwei große räume werden zu
schlafsälen umfunktioniert die küche
instand gesetzt und neue bäder
installiert in krakau leben mittlerweile
150 tausend flüchtlinge die stadt ist
mit ihren aufnahme einrichtungen an der
belastungsgrenze die 40 plätze hier in
der gemeinde sind begehrt man kümmert
sich hier um uns wie in einer familie
wir bekommen unterstützung für
verwaltungs anträge schulsachen für die
kinder manche gehen schulhof polnischen
schulen und auch das organisiert die
gemeinde ich glaube nicht dass das alles
möglich wäre wenn wir privat
untergebracht wären
victoria matlok kennt kaum noch pausen
gemeindemitglieder wollen wissen welche
sachspenden noch gebraucht werden und
die stadt ob noch ein bett frei wäre die
regierung hilft natürlich auch aber es
ist alles recht bürokratisch die
menschen brauchen ja sofort
unterstützung ein dach über dem kopf die
möglichkeit sich zu waschen darauf kann
man nicht warten bis anträge ausgefüllt
sind die kinder bekommen ihr polnisch
unterricht parallel geht es weiter mit
dem schulstoff auf ukrainisch die kinder
machen weiter hier mit ihrem
ukrainischen lehrer er ist im ausland
und gibt von dort aus online unterricht
darauf dass alle länger bleiben müssen
stellt sich auch victoria matlok ein und
versucht den flüchtlingsfrauen ein
gefühl von würde und zuversicht zu geben
ja jede menge geflüchtete brauchen noch
jede menge hilfe und so ginge es über
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und alles
für sie zum nachlesen auch auf spenden
punkt zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite
vor allem das wissen sie energiepreise
haben sich durch den krieg massiv
verteuert der chef der bundesnetzagentur
fordert in der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung dass privathaushalte
schon jetzt höhere monatliche abschläge
auf ihren verbrauch zahlen sollten
erhöhe man die abschläge erst nächstes
jahr treffe es viele menschen
unvorbereitet so behördenchef klaus
müller
jetzt zu corona da sinken die
infektionszahlen in deutschland weiter
bundesweit meldet das rk ii 196 1456
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
55 1570 weniger als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen innerhalb eines tages
292 todesfälle hinzu die sieben tage
incidents ist leicht gesunken auf etwa
1.500 31
an diesem wochenende ist es in fast
allen bundesländern so weit die meisten
gesetzlichen corona schutzmaßnahmen
laufen aus und was dann bleibt ist ein
basisschutz außerhalb von hotspot
regionen soll es eine masken pflicht nur
noch begrenzt geben etwa in kliniken in
pflegeheimen in bussen oder bahnen für
die meisten bereiche aber gilt jetzt die
2g die 3g regeln und die masken dürfen
fallen oliver deuker mit einem
stimmungsbild aus hannover zwei jahre
pandemie zwei jahre einschränkungen doch
jetzt eine zeitenwende in den meisten
bereichen fehlt die masken pflicht also
ich freue mich natürlich dass
lockerungen kommen aber ich sehe das
ganze ist ein bisschen skeptisch dass
ich denke ich mir nach wie vor maßgenau
auf zb supermarkt also ich finde es gut
dass es in die individuelle
verantwortung jedes einzelnen abgegeben
wird wenn man was getragen wird und so
wie sie tragen wenn nicht sowas lassen
muss ich das selber wissen und rücken
bin ich schon sterben immer noch jeden
tag 200 bis 300 leute eine
mittelständische firma in hannover der
chef hier nutzt sein hausrecht besteht
weiter auf maske tragen bei betreten
seiner firma und in der kantine
dass wir hielten das für inkonsequent
und für wenig schlau wenn wir auf die
masken pflicht verzichten wir haben hier
im krankenstand erheblich ist knapp
unter zehn prozent im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr beim arzt in
krankenhäusern und altersheimen besteht
aber weiterhin masken pflicht dieser
basis schutz reicht aber nach meinung
von patientenschützer nicht aus gefährde
die wunde rebellengruppen stichwort
gerona test hier bedarf es der täglichen
tests pflicht für die mitarbeiter vom
dienst gehen das gibt es aber nicht und
somit zieht sich das leiden und sterben
weiter fort hohe inzidenz 'nen führen
dazu dass täglich mehrere hundert
menschen sterben die wir eigentlich gut
schützen können die kostenlosen
schnelltests für jedermann wird es aber
noch weiterhin geben vorerst bis ende
juni die neuen lockerung zu früh zu
inkonsequent kritisieren viele fachleute
die jetzt im frühling schon vor dem
nächsten herbst warnen
ab morgen gelten die neuen core ohne
regeln warum werden manche bundesländer
zu hot spots erklärt und andere nicht
also welche kriterien sind entscheidend
dazu finden sie in unserer zdf heute app
eine ausführliche bestandsaufnahme
wir schauen jetzt nach frankreich dort
findet in gut einer woche die
präsidentschaftswahl statt emanuele
makro will weiter im amt bleiben seine
wahrscheinlichste konkurrentin in einer
möglichen stichwahl ist die
rechtspopulistin marin lippen makro
präsentierte sich in den letzten wochen
als krisenmanager im ukraine krieg erst
jetzt steigt der amtsinhaber mit einer
einzigen großen veranstaltung in den
wahlkampf ein thomas walde aus paris
der präsident betritt die arena
die wucht des auftritts die inszenierung
sollen zeigen immer nur meckern ist da
in den vergangenen wochen konzentrierte
er sich fernab der öffentlichkeit auf
den krieg in der ukraine heute ganz auf
die innen und sozialpolitik makro
verteidigte seine bilanz die
arbeitslosigkeit sei historisch niedrig
er kündigte programme für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit und bessere
aufstiegschancen
durch arbeit durch produktion können wir
in den kommenden fünf jahren unser
wachstum steigern mehr wohlstand
schaffen und den fortschritt fortsetzen
[Musik]
marien präsidentin laut umfragen ist die
nationalisten marine le pen macros
hauptkonkurrenten dass sie in der
vergangenheit wladimir putin verteidigte
will sie vergessen machen sie sammelt
die stimmen der unzufriedenen verspricht
die kaufkraft der arbeitenden menschen
zu erhöhen zuwanderung zu beschränken
was als obligatorische wiederwahl
emanuel makros angekündigt wurde erweist
sich als fake news es ist wirklich
möglich emanuel makro zu schlagen
unter zahlreichen linken kandidatin gilt
john lee miller schon als der
aussichtsreichste mindestlohn weniger
arbeitszeit höhere steuern für
gutverdiener und rente schon ab 60
menschen will radikale veränderung der
frauchen franzosen müssen absolut
souverän sein wir verteidigen uns ganz
allein darum haben wir nach meiner
meinung nichts in der nato zu suchen die
kandidatin der einstmals bedeutenden
sozialistischen und konservativen
parteien gelten als chancenlos so
zeichnet sich in frankreich eine wahl ab
zwischen einem weiter so und radikaler
veränderung
zu einem anderen urnengang und damit
zurück nach deutschland genauer
schleswig holstein noch gut fünf wochen
bis zur landtagswahl dort
ministerpräsident günther von der cdu
liegt nach jüngsten umfragen deutlich
vor gefolgt von spd und den grünen
demnach würde es für eine zweite
amtszeit der schwarz grün gelben jamaika
koalition reichen denkbar wären aber
auch andere bündnisse vom
wahlkampfauftakt in kiel herrmann bernd
im kieler landtag wird der wahlomat
freigeschaltet auch
cdu-ministerpräsident daniel günther ist
dabei nach jüngsten umfragen hat er gute
chancen sein amt zu behalten
er ist mit großem abstand beliebteste
politiker im land sein wahlkampfmotto
kurs halten ich meine ziele sind das wir
version schon weiter regieren ich würde
am liebsten in der jamaika-koalition
auch weiter regieren weil ich fest davon
überzeugt bin dass die letzten fünf
jahre gute jahre für schleswig holstein
waren dass wir das land gut regiert
haben
spd-spitzenkandidat thomas lohse müller
setzt auf rot grün oder einer ampel mit
der fdp bis vor kurzem war noch mitglied
der grünen jetzt ist der genosse sein
problem er ist im land noch nicht so
bekannt so ein wahlkampf ist der hat
jetzt erst begonnen und das heißt die
zeit in der man bekannt wird die fängt
jetzt erst an das ist eben so wenn man
als quereinsteiger mit erfahrung von
außerhalb der politik in die politik
kommt spitzenkandidatin der grünen ist
monika heinold die finanzministerin in
der jamaika koalition möchte
ministerpräsidentin werden ihr kernthema
ist der klimaschutz vor allem der
weitere ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
nach der wahl sehen wir was möglich ist
mit unserem programm sagen wir sehr klar
dass wir eigenständig sind dass es keine
koalitionsaussage vor der wahl gibt
wirtschaftsminister buchholz geht für
die fdp ins rennen er will vor allem die
digitalisierung vorantreiben und den
straßenbau und bildung investieren und
jano jamaika fortsetzen wir haben noch
ein bisschen was zu tun wir kommen
erfahren so ausgangspositionen 98 9% und
wir wollen mehr selbstbewusst tritt der
südschleswigsche wählerverband auf im
norden von der fünf prozent hürde
befreit hält man sich alle optionen
offen also die schließe gar nichts aus
sondern erst mal gesagt geht es darum
gutes ergebnis für den ssw und
bereitschaft besteht mit allen
demokratischen parteien zu reden hat die
umfragen sehen die afg und ihren
spitzenkandidaten jörg nobis wieder
sicher im landtag mein ziel wäre eine 7
vorm komma noch besser wäre nacht vorm
komma aber ich weiß dass die bäume nicht
in den himmel wachsen
am 8 mai wird im norden gewählt der
wahlkampf jedenfalls kommt jetzt richtig
auf touren
papst franziskus denkt darüber nach die
einladung ukrainischer politiker
anzunehmen und nach kiew zu reisen das
sagte er zu beginn seiner balkanreise
franziskus verurteilte den krieg als
infantile und zerstörerische aggression
wichtiges thema bei seinem besuch ist
die migration
sie verlangen nach gemeinsamen antworten
so der papst ist dürfe nicht sein dass
nur einige länder das gesamte problem
tragen müssen
für die gläubigen muslime hat der
islamische fastenmonat ramadan begonnen
in mekka in saudi arabien versammelten
sich die pilger zum gebet und umrundeten
die kaaba das wichtigste heiligtum des
islam während des ramadan verzichten
gläubige tagsüber auf essen und trinken
nach islamischer überlieferung wurde den
propheten mohammed im fast monat der
koran offenbart weltweit gibt es etwa
1,9 milliarden muslime
wir machen jetzt mit dem sport und katja
und fußball weiter so sieht's aus wir
beginnen mit der fußball bundesliga und
da es in der partie freiburg gegen die
bayern knapp 60 minuten nach einer
nullnummer aus dann aber drehten die
münchner auf hier die ergebnisse des 28
spieltags die bayern gewinnen also in
freiburg 4 zu 1 leverkusen hertha 2 zu 1
hoffenheim unterliegt bochum 1 zu 2
frankfurt und reuter führt trennen sich
torlos 1 1 endergebnis zwischen
bielefeld und stuttgart am abend das
topspiel dortmund gegen leipzig mit
erster free tv bildern und allen
wichtigen stimmen im aktuellen
sportstudio und bereits gestern union
berlin gegen erster fc köln 1 zu 0 in
der tabelle die bayern jetzt neun punkte
vor dem bvb der am abend aber wieder
verkürzen kann dahinter bis platz sechs
keine veränderungen zur vorwoche union
berlin schiebt sich an köln und
frankfurt vorbei auf rang sieben mainz
mit zwei spielen weniger an der spitze
der zweiten tabellenhälfte bochum und
gladbach auf 11 und 12 tauschen die
plätze genauso wie bielefeld und hertha
im keller schlusslicht weiter greuther
fürth
zu gast im aktuellen sportstudio ist
heute abend felix zweier der fifa
schiedsrichter gibt einblicke in die
guten aber auch in die schlechten seiten
seines jobs spricht über anfeindungen
und drohungen los gehts 23 uhr thema
dann auch die auslosung zur fußball wm
in katar gestern abend die entscheidung
deutschland bekommt es in der
gruppenphase mit spanien japan und costa
rica oder neuseeland zu tun spannend
interessant reizvoll attestierte unter
anderem der bundestrainer
losfee lothar matthäus mit einem
süffisanten lächeln bundestrainer hansi
flick mit bemühter coolness spanien als
gruppengegner da fällt einem sofort das
0 6 vom november 2020 ein und beim
letzten wm duell 2010 verwehrte spanien
mit einem 1 0 im halbfinale deutschland
den finaleinzug vergangenheit
interessiert mich null komma null es
geht jetzt darum dass wir
einfach neu angefangen haben neustadt
gehabt und bis jetzt hat die mannschaft
ist sehr gut umgesetzt und wir wollen
jetzt spiel für spiel einfach uns normal
und sich verbessern ein wunschgegner ist
deutschland aber auch für die spanier
nicht
okay das ist wie ich die beste
mannschaft die man bekommen konnte in
deutschland war das stärkste team für
mich aus topf 2 aber wie auch immer alle
mannschaften sind hier weil sie große
mannschaften haben japan und entweder
costa rica oder neuseeland zählen zu den
sogenannten machbaren aufgaben
überraschungspotenzial ist aber auch bei
diesen gegnern nicht ausgeschlossen
bisschen zeit ist noch november dezember
dann die spielzeit ich kann mich immer
noch nicht herangewagt hat ja so es gibt
ein bisschen neuschnee im süden einige
schauer im norden dazwischen auch sonne
meer sonntagswetter gleich mit katja
horneffer das heute journal mit den
neuesten informationen um 21 uhr 45 mit
christian sievers das gesamte 19 uhr
team sagt schönen dank schönen abend und
bis mo
[Musik]
guten abend umzingelt von gleich sechs
teams nimmt das hoch quincy reißaus in
richtung azoren und hier kommt schon ein
neues stürmisches tieferen dass uns dann
am wochenanfang beehrt jetzt müssen erst
mal die schneefälle nach in
süddeutschland die zehn sich im laufe
der nacht immer mehr richtung alpenrand
zurück und von nordwesten kommen schon
neue schnee regen und regenschauer auf
dazwischen aber ist es klar und dann
sinken die temperaturen hier im
nordhessischen bergland im
rothaargebirge oder auch im sauerland
bis auf minus zehn grad da gibt es also
noch mal strengen frost frostfrei bleibt
es dagegen an den küsten von ost und
nordsee die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen in bayern bei 1 bis 3 grad sonst
werden 4 bis 8 grad erreicht und morgen
vormittag kann es im allgäu noch die
letzten schneeflocken geben sonst wird
es freundlich aber über norddeutschland
ziehen doch etliche regen und schnee
regenschauer hinweg und dann wird es
wenn nicht dann kommen diese stürmische
tiefer montag heran besonders an der
nordseeküste pfeift ein böiger wind aus
westlichen richtungen der dienstag wird
dann recht verregnet der mittwoch
deutlich milder bei 7 bis 15 grad
schönes wochenende